no one was at higher risk more than you
this ufc fighter
ufc fighter cheyenne buys
cries after receiving a 50 thousand
dollar bonus after winning her fight
this was last week she says she was
negative in her bank account and
completely
broke prior to this 50 000 bonus this is
a story from bro bible what's up bro
cheyenne bai says her life changed after
her last fight
during her ufc her fight at ufc vegas 33
baies finished off her opponent gloria
de paula in the co-main event during her
post-fight
interview buzz raised some eyebrows when
she said that she was completely
broke after recently moving to vegas
after receiving the 50 000 bonus from
the performance of the night
an emotional buy said
man it's just been a long road to get
here it's it's been crazy crazy fight
camp for me this is my impression of
harassment
i left my home in dallas
and i just packed up
i left my home with everything in it and
i'm broke as hell i mean i'm so broke i
just got a loan so i can pay for the
house here
and this is the quote
i was so broke my whole life because of
this sport ufc but it's so worth it to
me because i love
this sport so this begs the question
do you pursue your passion
or do you pay
the bills so to put in a little
perspective
what happens if she lost that fight
she'd be broke
homeless
dying to do another fight when you know
how they say when you're broke you're
desperate when you're desperate you do
stupid things yeah so thank god you want
i mean i would like to actually you know
what's funny the person that lost this
uh
the paula yeah gloria paula let's
let's see what her bank account is
looking like this fifty thousand dollars
changed her life
she's probably gonna you know reinvest
it into the sport that she loves but it
begs the question pursue your passion or
pay the bills i remember i started when
i was 24 years old i started doing
stand-up comedy i was like you know i've
been thinking about doing stand-up
comedy my whole life i'm gonna get
started i started at a comedy club in
denver when i was living there for a
year comedy works in denver i was on the
grind i moved back to miami i was doing
comedy at the improv i was um doing it
uh just all throughout miami at the hard
rock
and you know they pay you nothing they
pay me 25 bucks 100 bucks if you're just
you know you're an opening act what have
you
you know i was doing nightlife at the
time
but i was pursuing my passion but i was
broke as hell and i was living on
friends couches it's not a fun existence
so the question is is better to pursue
your passion or is it better to pay the
bills you know pbd has some advice here
you got something to weigh in on this
paul uh i do yeah i
i think if you have the actual passion
for it i think it's worth it because the
victory
there's nothing like that right but
which victory
like that girl that emotion that she
felt not every person gets to experience
that right but it's
it's pure bliss like it's one of the
best uh feelings what happens if she
would have lost that fight she would
have kept she was broke no she would
have gotten no money yeah of course she
would have kept going but my point is
but you have to have that passion like
if you don't like say you're just like
ah
it's cool but i don't love it yeah then
then then i don't recommend that you're
doing that right that's basically where
i was at in the comedy thing i love it
it's fun but like i'm not i'm being
broke and i got a job in finance it's
worked out well for me
circle back i actually
10 years later opened up my own comedy
club in south beach right it's now i'm
not no longer involved in it but
basically i circled back to my passion
so this brings me to something that pbd
says all the time he basically says
there's four phases of life
first phase of life when you're
basically from you know a young kid to
age 20 or something
number one just don't it up
don't do anything that gets you in jail
don't do anything that gets you killed
or
basically ruins your reputation just
don't it up you're young you can
make mistakes but
something that you don't do something
you can't recover from
phase two
from 20 to 40 let's say make that money
make that money that's basically what i
did from age 26 to age 40 now i've made
money
third phase 40
40. you look great thank you buddy i
really appreciate that compliments will
get you everywhere phase three i can
hold the burritos too um
pay five grand a day oh yeah uh phase
three this is according to pbd then you
can start to work on your creative side
and pursue your passion obviously pat is
doing that with valuetainment you know
pat you know do you use pat as example
when he was young he did some stupid
stuff he talks about all the time but he
didn't do anything enough to screw up
his future correct
phase two from his early twenties
and now he's 42 he basically killed it
in the insurance game php we all know it
now phase three of his life he's working
on his passion his creative side
valuetainment that's where we are here
now and phase four he talks about this a
20-year run here but when he's in his
60s and beyond um he'll give back and
you know i'm sure he's got big plans
with that so anyway the bottle he's
already given back as well let's not act
like he that's true but these are this
is this is basically what he talks about
right here
so
you talked about building your personal
brand build your personal brand cheyenne
right like your people are talking about
you now
turn um lemons into lemonade right here
but um
save that money cheyenne yeah save that
money she's broke as hell ufc fighter
um save that money cheyenne hopefully
she's listening and or listening to that
type of advice so that's my advice to
save that money
all we talk is money
if you enjoyed that short clip from the
sauce cast click here to watch another
click here to watch the full episode or
just stay broken